Speaker 1: Let's go next to Daniel from Nevada.
Daniel, welcome.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Hello?
Can you hear.
Speaker 1: Me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Awesome.
I've been trying to catch you for months.
Speaker 1: Well, here we are.
Let's make it worthwhile.
Speaker 2: Oh.
So in recent years.
So.
Oh.
There's big stuff happening in America.
And.
And it's really bad.
But I feel like there's stuff in other countries
as well that I think needs more attention.
Speaker 1: Okay, give me an example.
Speaker 2: So an example of my, um.
I only know about this because my best friend
loser.
So in the Philippines, there was this bill
early this year and the president let it lapse.
Speaker 1: Into law from 30 days of.
Speaker 2: Not signing it or vetoing it.
And it's called the Social Media SIM Card
and Social Media Registration Act.
Hmm.
And it basically and the things it does is
require all Filipino citizens to one register
their legal name and ID will SIM card if they
have.
Speaker 1: And Daniel, I hate to interrupt
you.
I just here's the thing I want to say to you.
For for the average American, that's just
not a more important issue than the domestic
issues that we're dealing with.
I don't I don't know about that issue, the
registration of SIM cards in the Philippines,
but it's not that's not like my audience.
If I we do like a show about here's issues
facing the country if I talk about that's
not it's not more important for people here
it's just not and I don't deny that it's a
relevant issue.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Well, but the second part is, is the part
that's, like, really bad.
It requires the whole country to dox themselves
on social media.
Right.
You can't you cannot use a username.
You have to use your real name on your social
media account.
Okay.
Basically doxing them under penalty of law
with a penalty of minimum six years imprisonment
or $200,000.
Speaker 1: If that's as you describe.
That sounds bad.
But from the perspective of the United States,
where we've got a broken health care system,
we're trying to figure out how to prevent
the rise of a fascistic authoritarian MAGA
right wing.
We're trying to deal with all of these different
issues and the environment and all these different
things.
The fact that you've got to dox yourself on
social media in the Philippines.
I'm not saying that it's not important to
the people there, but it's not really an issue
that in the U.S. is going to get a lot of
attention.
Okay?
Yeah, it just.
It just is what it is, you know?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend.
Thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.
There's always lots of important issues.
It's just not that.
I just don't know that that is like the perfect
example of the issue that's being missed in
American media necessarily.
Let's take a very quick break.
If you're holding to talk to me, don't hang
up because we're going right back to the phones
in a moment.